well trying to stop Diplomat wearing
years holding talks in Moscow with
Russian foreign minister Sergey lavrov
China says it stands on Russia's
invasion of Ukraine is neutral this is
his last stop on an eight-day
international tour that included visits
to France Italy and Hungary and to the
Munich security conference let's get
more on this from our correspondent
Osama bin Javed who's in Moscow for us
obviously an important meeting for Wang
Yi in Moscow what do we expect him to
say there
but as you've heard from wangi in the
last few days that China wants to play
the role of an Arbiter of Peace it wants
to bring the two sides close to the
negotiating table it wants to play this
neutral role but there is symbolism in
wangi being here he's not just the
former foreign minister but he's now the
director of the commit the Foreign
Affairs committee at the Chinese
Communist Party he's the the top
Diplomat if we can call him that in
China so it does send a message that
China stands with Moscow at this hour of
moscow's need as moscow's being isolated
elsewhere it does send the message that
China is going to try and play the role
of a friend or not just a neutral
laborator so he's met Sergey lavrov
today China has been floating this
so-called security plan and another plan
for to find peace between the two sides
there are reports that this has been
circulated to Kiev as well and will be
unveiled closer to or on the day of the
anniversary but of course China is very
important when it comes to Moscow not
just because of symbolism but also
because of the harsh sanctions that
Russia has been facing from the west and
because of help from China and its
Central Asian allies it's been able to
circumvent most of them and of course
closer to home to where you are
certainly strong reaction from the
Russian government to Biden's speech in
Poland what less than 24 hours ago I
mean what's the government been saying
but we've just heard this morning from
the security Council District State
security Council Dimitri Medvedev a very
strong reaction to Biden's speech
calling it a pack of Lies saying that he
was addressing the Russian people while
standing in Poland and saying calling it
bizarre but towards the end of uh his uh
his speech there's a really interesting
quote and if I can quote him directly he
says that to paraphrase the expression
that Biden said in Wars so that if
Russia stops its Invasion the war will
stop and if Moscow if Kiev stops fight
defending themselves it will be the end
of Ukraine to that he says this is a
redefined lie and the truth is quite
different according to Moscow if Russia
stops the special military operation
without achieving Victory Russia will
cease to exist it will be Torn to Pieces
while if the U.S stops supplying weapons
to the key of regime the war will come
to an end so you see that both sides
seem to be on a very different tangent
when it comes to what their a version of
peace is how will the war stop and as
you've heard from President Vladimir
Putin saying and pulling out suspending
rather the new Star treaty as well that
there seems to be no uh close end in
sight to this one-year conflict in
Ukraine for the update thanks very much
Forrest uh in Moscow Let's cross over to
Beijing now where Katrina you is
standing by and Katrina Chinese
relationship with Russia has sort of
come under deep scrutiny really since
the invasion of Ukraine I mean it
continues to tout this sort of No Limits
friendship with Russia despite the
suspicion that it raises
that's right China's Global image
certainly has taken a battering from its
enduring relationship with Russia but we
have to remember there are number a
number of very important things that
Beijing does get from having such close
ties with Moscow one is very cheap and
reliable Imports of energy China relies
on Russia for cheap Imports of gas and
oil second is a peaceful Northern
neighbor and third is a very reliable
friend in its Corner that shares
beijing's world view China and the
Communist parties specifically is
working and really wants to reshape the
global order into one where the U.S and
other Democratic Western countries are
less influential because that will give
China more leeway to pursue its own
interests for example in the South China
Sea and around Taiwan so it needs
friends like Russia and though China may
want to see the end of this conflict in
Ukraine it will not serve China to see a
weakened Putin or a weakened Russia so
it's continuing to invest in this
relation relationship with this visit by
Wong Yi and even potentially rumors of a
potential visit from president Xi
Jinping himself to Russia in the spring
and of course you know Wang Yi the
foreign minister isn't really the only
sort of big name that we recognize that
sort of making this diplomatic push
across Europe at the moment China in
itself has seen a lot of diplomatic
moves recently what's the overall goal
here
that's right we have Chinese officials
crisscrossing the globe we've had a
meeting taking place in Japan we've had
another one take place in Indonesia this
week I think overall this also comes off
the heels of this balloon incident with
hap which happened with the US where
Washington contends that it was a
Chinese spy balloon it shot down earlier
in the month so I think Beijing really
wants to take back to the narrative and
put itself forward as a mediator and a
promoter of global peace and stability
and although China knows it's not going
to win any hearts and Minds in in the US
and with Western European countries it
does it does seem to be aware that there
are other countries particularly in the
developing world that may be a bit more
ambivalent about Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and maybe more open to seeing
China's reasons for wanting to continue
its relationship with Russia and I think
it's those countries in particular that
China is trying to speak to and trying
to project itself forward as a
alternative blow Global responsible
player and certainly an alternative to
the US
there in Beijing thanks Katrina
and we have a week-long special series
on the far-reaching consequences of the
Ukraine war a year into the conflict I
hope you can join us and tune in at 11
30 GMT and 16 30 GMT on Wednesday and
also at 0230 GMT on Thursday where my
colleague Adrian Finnegan will be
exploring the human impact of the war
from Kiev